[Applause]
civilians took cover on the floor of
passport control as fighting ranged on
the grounds
as military aircraft fly low above the
capital
[Music]
firing at least one missile
above anti-aircraft artillery blasting
through the streets people in cartoon
the capital woke up to the sounds of
gunfire and heavy artillery I in fact
live not too far from the Republican
Palace downtown Khartoum
tension had been boiling between the
Sudanese Army and the rapid support
forces and and we're seeing this
materializing today in the capital
the nightmare scenario many have feared
has come to be the long Brewing power
struggle between the Army and the
powerful paramilitary rapid support
forces has erupted in gunfire and
explosions across Sudan's capital
I can't leave here says one resident
filming burning planes on the airport
tarmac
thank you
it's a tug of war with no clear weapons
and civilians everything to lose
[Applause]
Sky News